I had a fairly standard childhood hurry
there isn't much time with parents who
couldn't wait to get me out of the house
you are destined for greatness that was
a lot of expectation to place on an 8
day old turns out another family in the
Glau Punk quadrant had a very similar
idea
that was the day I met mr. goody
two-shoes and our glorious rivalry was
born our battles quickly got more
elaborate I can't trap justice he would
win some I would almost win others he
took the name Metro man I decided to
pick something a little more humble
megabyte incredibly handsome master of
all villainy this year all right put
your hands in the air the battle between
good and evil
Megamind will blow your mind
don't panic
Roxy I'm on my way oh I'm shaking in my
custom baby C leather boots your plans
never work you're so predictable
you call this predictable I was thinking
about it on the way over the spiders new
spider yes the spider even the smallest
bite from Iraq nice death ickis will
instantly paralyze reworks mega mine in
3d